hey guys we are back hunting Pokemon
today but I'm joined with Jenna and Matt
they walked over 10 miles in Sirte
catching pokémon sure my knee hurt
that's crazy
so the proper way to catch pokemon is to
make sure you have a backpack because
you want to have both hands-free in your
backpack you want to have a low pain
charged pool a long enough chorus Wow
the multi is in your back
alright you guys right
catching them but I'm not quite catching
them all
gotcha gotcha
there's a huge blue guy right here
poliwag do you happen that has all of
this he's cheating
we got so many leaves over here which
means Pokemon
economic in real-time hunting with you
small so I'm not sure you guys can see
it's super brave we've got a triple
bogey SOT module set up oh and there's
another pokemon right here
people are cruising in for our triple
modules like this is crazy like pokemon
goes to weird phenomena this is so
bullet just like this set up a triple
module and there are four modules is
great we need to find some more areas
like that
but explain to it like this is insane
like this is absolutely guys I know how
crazy this is people are walking to
these pokey stops just insanity
hi hi Jenna how are you laughter I'm
vlogging say hi yay stealing my power
back a little bit
well to be fair it was dangling and I
thought I would do you a favor
let's go eat dinner next to a gym okay I
know where they're going back yeah
everyone is playing they're playing
Pokemon you know that okay if someone is
going like this and swiping on their
phone they're focused they're playing
Pokemon over there they're playing
Pokemon
we're playing Pokemon look all these
people
hi guys I have another egg that's about
the hatch I don't know which one it is
but we'll see it's actually pretty
decent CP of 368 and I'm only ten
candies are whoa wait I can involve the
top Oh a long time ago I had no idea
Matt have a question for you did you
ever think that this is where your life
would take you right now I don't think
anybody will ever know how much I
actually like blind in Pokemon as a kid
for me this is like a dream come true
while we're walking around and meeting
all these people that are just in the
middle of populated places playing the
game it's going to go down as one of the
biggest like 21st century pop-culture
phenomenon
really
I
well I am an adult and I'm having a good
kilometer AG and it just disappeared
okay so clearly you know just hanging
out and catch a Pokemon and it stops us
it was like we are pokédex s we're like
connecting well I saw somebody running
toward I was like oh my gosh oh my gosh
your grinder lovely you know blah blah
love it
I'm trying to stay on top so much Runyan
I think we need to do it again
it's got my time when it's not long it
is so my issue at all okay so Pokemon
cool and actually me oh and go to bed
now because now we got to do a stroll
through third Street okay fine mad
Pokemon inside
what who owns this van God that is
incredible but also like not good at the
same time but if we left pull up you
understand humor it wow guys I had an
egg they just hatched it was a I already
have this whoa holy moly guys I just got
something that looks like you got those
proud do you have him
no I don't have any grass pokemon
Bellsprout you yeah at all mom what did
I get what I get what I get I got the
damn pony again so last night we went
Pokemon hunting announced the next
morning I'm about to edit this vlog Matt
is obsessed like we actually think that
he might have a problem like last night
we were driving back and Jenna was like
you know I really think I might need a
Pokemon break and Matt looked at her and
was like but we had so much fun
yesterday it's like what we play good
play for 14 hours the best two days like
14 hours each day I think I might just
need like a little break and it was like
I said I hated him I think it was
probably even like the worst possible
thing that you could ever think to say
to somebody that was like what genocide
time
I wanted to film but I I don't I felt
bad because he was super upset about it
all right I'm gonna go Maddie does not
like pokemons go because it really
affects his walks because we'll be
walking and then we have to stop to
catch well now we know how he feels with
us because he stops the pee laughs I'm
always stopping to pee on everything hi
did you have a good breakfast hmm this
is the image that everyone's been going
crazy about it says if you're wondering
what the iPhone 7 should look like